liebe zuschauer wieder mal liegt eine
sehr denkwürdige praxis woche hinter uns
endlose hängepartie ganz europa fragt
sich inzwischen wann kommen sie endlich
zu potte diese hänge briten
es kann doch nicht wahr sein drei tage
braucht das britische unterhaus müssen
darüber dass bildschirm weg kommen ja
drei tage braucht das britische
unterhaus um nochmal festzustellen dass
die theresa may stil mit der eu nicht
wollen aber keinen deal wollen sie auch
nicht sagt doch endlich mal was ihr
wollt jetzt mal ehrlich wie lange soll
sich dieser komische abschied der noch
hinziehen
vielleicht verlassen wir die eu dann
über monate hin noch nicht oder wir
haben nicht mehr den schutz oder wir
treten vielleicht nie aus jetzt wird
heraus tritt also wohl verschoben aber
für was für was und wie viele
niederlagen musste ebay noch passieren
bevor sie mal zurück tritt nach all den
demütigungen das geht ja fast schon in
den schadow war so bereich meine damen
und herren wirklich nächsten dienstag
diskutieren zum dritten mal dieselben
englischen politiker mit denselben
argumenten denselben deal dass kein
parlament ist eine demenz klinik wenn
sie mich fragen ehrlich jetzt mal was
soll man zu den leuten wie boris johnson
überhaupt noch sagen we can't we made
you win win situation autos messe also
warum können wir aus diesem ganzen elend
nicht eine win win situation machen habe
ich sage lieber borries wurde überall
kot jaja rothbart geht ja nicht
peter nicht und selbst mit einem zweiten
referendum dinge ja alles nur von vorne
los was wenn wieder die doofen gewinnen
ja meistens gewinnen die doofen die sind
fast überall in überzahl wirklich dieser
engländer kommen wir inzwischen vor wir
sind partygast leute da mit der sich
schon vor einer stunde verabschiedet hat
und einfach nicht kraft dass wirklich
alle wohl dass er endlich abhaut alte
regel nichts ist nerviger als leute die
einfach kein gefühl dafür wann endlich
schluss ist auf jeden fall im
binnenmarkt bleiben aber natürlich ohne
im binnenmarkt zu bleiben
ja klar es steht eine menge auf dem
spiel
1,2 billionen dollar haben allein banken
und hedgefonds jetzt schon von der insel
runter geholt dabei ist noch gar nicht
weg sind
ich glaube viele engländer haben die
konsequenzen gar nicht kapiert andere
versuchen wenigstens zu helfen
sie fahren zurzeit sonderschichten beim
süßwarenhersteller katjes am niederrhein
und schicken so viel lakritze und
fruchtgummi nach großbritannien gehen
der grund sie rechnen mit dem
schlimmsten das möchte mir gar nicht
ausmalen wenn die komplette fred ferkel
versorgung großbritanniens
zusammenbricht weil da munter und man
darf ja nie vergessen wer die ganze lief
kampagne also den kampf für fish n chips
finanziert hat britische milliardäre
waren das die aus england nach dem break
sind eine steueroase machen wollen darum
geht es nicht um patriotismus leute wie
james radcliffe der reichste mann
englands lieben ihr land aber nicht so
sehr dass sie selber da bleiben würden
der prominente praxis befürworter
verlegt seinen wohnsitz nach monaco
seinem angeblich so geliebten vaterland
könnten so bis zu vier milliarden pfund
an steuern entgehen in james dyson gilt
eigentlich als befürworter des brh exit
mit dem umzug nach singapur wolle sich
draußen auf die wachsenden asiatischen
märkte konzentrieren ja genau das glaube
ich sofort wieder schön den stöpsel aus
der insel ziehen und sich dann selber
verpissen wir reden hier natürlich auch
über wahnvorstellungen das ist fakt
viele brachse befürworter wollen der
backstop lösung für irland nicht
zustimmen weil sie angst
die böse eu sie dann für immer im
binnenmarkt hält das will überhaupt
keiner hier ja viele grüße aus
griechenland oder liebe briten wie man
auf ostdeutsch sagen würde ein bisschen
hart
wir gehen ganz europa in geiselhaft so
und für alle die inzwischen echt
probleme haben unsere an sich geliebten
mallorca nachbarn noch zu verstehen hier
der passende nachhilfeunterricht
english for work city als mitglied
vieler hosten
[Musik]
hallo mein name ist tina enz bei visit
ist oliver kivanc to understand braig
sit ja genau wer kein mensch versteht
mir diese engländer oliver englisch sehr
britisch stand von kadir but i don't
want note lassen wollen
accident ass well it's not present time
this is what we call sind dreifache
verneinung oder say in german sind
britisch have one fc basel einen an der
waffel okay tina i have just one
question
und das sieht man ja nobody knows that
the british akku meetings sei tänze
question is who can save europe online
schotte halt so wurden putsch in frose
bettkante
tiefrot in letter to angela merkel bis
fresh ideas for europe hat angela diesen
freitag ist etwa compter letter from the
strange klinik women's saarland nina
bott ist saarland will oliver see
saarland ist es an ihnen bundesland
smaller sind bielefeld seppel aufs
saarland akkord salafist anyway diese
cleaning moment said no go fresh ideas
however ski hätte great idea hass auf
die cdu vorsitzende hat angeregt mit
frankreich zusammen einem gemeinsamen
europäischen flugzeugträger zu bauen
die pilze flugzeugträger ein love me
schlappe weekend evil repair bloody say
okay
this is our last lessons for today kids
peter paul and mary hat ryan to krax it
but i can't be called to fucking stupid
what now know we are going to the pub
und trinkt oder terrible englisch bier
an tobias ott rang wie vg trittin und
sexistisch sie oliver mätzke krank
prostata den aus
[Applaus]